hey leute willkommen zu crazy blockes
tag nummer drei und wir starten heute
den tag
es ist schon sehr viel ist schon dunkel
draußen aber es ist doch gar nicht so
spät es ist 16 und 30 16 uhr 30
da habt ihr gesehen dass ich gerade ein
vertrauensproblem habe denn ich konnte
nicht das wort entschuldigung auch ich
liebe die haare
ich arbeite noch instagram videos
gemacht ich habe sachen organisiert ich
musste blogs hochladen
es passiert ja immer viel deswegen
konnte ich nicht früher anfangen ich
werde heute noch mein arbeitszimmer
aufräumen also wahrscheinlich steht das
auch im titel ich räume ein crazy
verrücktes hässliches arbeitszimmer auf
aber jetzt wollte timo ein foto spontan
von mir machen und ich dachte ich nehme
das mal mit bestimmt dass das auch
spannend für euch eine kugel kreis
linien leser ja also eher ein kreuz
linien laser ich werde aussehen wie ein
geheimagent ich hasse es jetzt schon mit
diesem scheiß laser verein steht auf
diesem laser bitte nicht in die augen
und alle heimwerker werden jetzt sagen
wann es passt bloß bitte augen
ja mal ausrichten dass du quasi nicht
ich gucke auf jeden fall nicht in dem
die ich mache nur mein gesicht seitlich
es ist schon komisch nochmals zu machen
aber noch keine türchen auf machen zu
können
ticken zu früh ich sehe aus wie ein
geheimagent in dem den den den denn der
leser nicht hinter sondern dass er so
hier in der kant ist aber das war nicht
okay ich mache das nicht richtig so
richtig getrennt wann man fühlt sich so
richtig eklig ich will das gar nicht
mehr machen ich weiß wie man sich fühlt
war
ich weiß nichts über kopfschmerzen
gerade laser das sollen wir nicht mal
ins auge machen ich bin da auch ganz nah
vor dir mache ich gerne eins wir sehen
uns gleich wenn ich aufräume dieses
zimmer ist ein großer haufen kriegs
einfach nicht hin ich meine hier könnt
ihr einmal hinter die kulissen schauen
es auch ganz interessant ich meine dass
es noch gestern vom haare färben
aber ja grundsätzlich kann man schon
sagen dieses zimmer sind absolutes
chaotisches loch was ich unbedingt
unbedingt bezwingen muss meine güte
ich bin ich ein bisschen kaputt aber
heute war auch irgendwie ein
vollgestopfter tag ins schlafzimmer
sieht auch einfach nicht besser aus ich
bin aber auch blöd ich hab die ganze
zeit gedacht hier die ganze zeit gedacht
so nicht auf also ich freu mich nicht so
viel auf aber ich freue mich auch weil
die welt ja für langsam
ich muss ja aufgaben also es muss ja
ordentlich sein da wird natürlich vorher
nachher sieht was ziehe ich mir dann an
worin ich entspannt aufräumen kann jetzt
wie gelingt
ich meine wir sind im lochte wer außer
ihr 100000 menschen sehen mich ja jetzt
ich hab kein bock auf zugang ich denn er
ist mit euch
aber ich muss ich muss auch von dieses
zimmer sieht schon viel zu lange so
schlimm aus
die neuen herren gewöhnt weil ich hoffe
ihr habt einen schönen tag
es ist menschlich aber eigentlich ist er
da ist los so ist reinste beleuchtung er
war ich jetzt bin ich im dschungel
hallo ich bin im dschungel um mein gott
die nachbarn die armen nachbarn
erstmal kommt diese pflanze in die
badewanne wird mal wieder geduscht
es werde noch viel machen let's go
ich bin fertig oder ich hab das
aufgeräumt superklasse die zeit des
guten tons ist vorbei wir packen den
field recorder wieder ein falls sie
nicht wie so eine konstruktion aus sieht
ungefähr so ich lebe noch nicht auf dass
das nicht auch eine verwendung findet
diese tolle konstruktion ich bin sehr
stolz darauf hier im tempel aufgebaut
für meine freundin damit sie eine
wohnung krieg nicht mehr gewünscht habt
ja ich glaube an zauber machen das ist
mein weihnachts alltag hat sie schon mal
einen stream angeschaut habt wisst ihr
dass ich karten sehr gerne mag zum
beispiel solche karten die man sich dann
täglich zieht und dann zum beispiel hat
man hier selbstbewusstsein und dann
konzentriert man sich darauf und
versucht so die sehr bewusster ins
energie in sich zu finden und zu stärken
man könnte sagen dass es zauberei man
könnte aber auch sagen das ist einfach
positive vibes ins universum schicken
das ist das neue ich bin erwachsen warum
muss das immer so am ende bei mir
aussehen ich weiß ich arbeite hier aber
manchmal schaue ich timo an und sehe wie
toll der mit seinem ganzen kram umgeht
und wie gute aufhören dann nicht mehr
warum warum lieber gott kann ich das
nicht ich will euch ko-sieg wissen dass
feelings geben deswegen musikprogramm
ich brauche jetzt wo sie viel links ich
habe das jetzt schön auf das wird super
toll ich freue mich drauf
schön sieht doch schon besser aus das
sieht mein gott mein traum finger
schlechte träume
aber kommt er der mann des tages nicht
aus richtung klorolle hinkriegen rolle
in die küche
[Musik]
die leute wollen einfach nicht weiß wo
was sie sollen
[Musik]
jetzt schreibt sich jetzt sauber jetzt
kommen wir da zur hölle zu meiner
persönlichen
[Musik]
ok ich kann es erklären dass da oben ist
noch verpackungsmaterial was ich jetzt
an weihnachten brauchen werde
also macht es jetzt keinen sinn hier aus
zu packen oder guten weg zu packen weil
ich erzählen
24 tage brauche nicht weise sieht ja
vielleicht werde ich auch noch mal
zwischendurch
ich habe hier noch mal die ränder iv
karte gefunden also falls sie ein zwei
euro für den rentner ein herz für
rentner ev habt spendet gerne verwendung
für diesen scheiß hier
dann kommt meine ganzen weihnachts
verpackungsmaterial rein so nach 15
minuten arbeit bräuchten jetzt auch als
meine brot pause die vegane salami von
gröden beider
ich glaube ich muss nur noch den ort an
dem ich mal drehen zimmer sieht
ordentlich aus weil ich einfach so viel
drin steht
da hab ich auch überlegt noch zu
dekorieren beziehungsweise mein drehort
will ich hier einige bisschen
weihnachtlich gestalteten das ist halt
schön aussieht und eigentlich würde ich
auch gerne noch ein weihnachtliches bild
malen was ich im hintergrund stellen
kann ich liebe das lama echt sehr aber
das ist für mich eher so ein frühlings
bilden ich bräuchte ein winterbild man
fühlt sich aber schon viel wohler ist
absolut meine blogs online
0 aufrufen so die ersten die jetzt
schreiben die leiche ich alle bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
ich habe gegessen und jetzt wird noch
dieser bereich sauber gemacht und dann
bin ich fertig für heute also mit auf
rollen vielleicht waren wir noch kekse
50 40 angst mein zimmer ist abgeräumt
also es ist noch nicht sauber 1 ist
aufgeräumt hier ist alles sortiert ja
und ich glaube ich in bewährten morgen
weihnachtlich dekorieren
meine güte meine güte so hätte einmal
kurz apfel steht noch ein bisschen
quatsch aber aufgeräumt aufgeräumt
aufgereiht
ich habe gestern dann das erste mal
wieder champagner getrunken und musste
danach erstmal ordentlich feiern
timo ging es auch überhaupt nicht gut
jetzt auf den champagner geschmückt
das war der champagner und wir haben
nichts gegessen und aber ich weiß auch
nicht ich glaube es lag auch dann an
diesem komischen asiatischen lassen was
ich da bestellt hatte also gebracht nun
bestellte besser aus als ob man seine
jungen tüte einfach aufgewärmt hätte so
jetzt mache ich hier mal schicht im
schacht das wird jetzt hier mal
ausgemacht
aha ich heute noch kekse machen das ist
für dich an ihm soll ich kekse waren ich
rede dabei gleichzeitig in die kamera
anni soll ich kekse machen
nein das orakel sagt nein aufgemacht
käse wäre
zwar nicht gebacken bis heute kennt
zuzumachen
[Musik]
ich glaube dass nur lose familie zu
essen also meine haare sind nämlich
irgendwie anders aus sie kam zuletzt
play samurai spielen wie heißes spiel
[Musik]
die hat die eigentlich für meine
freundin gekauft die veganerin ist also
voll blut veganerin man hat sie selber
auf 120 lustig dass dann was wir
brauchen ist also an ihm die chance die
glocken videos auch sehr lecker das war
eine bezahlte werbung das ist jetzt aber
keine bezahlung werbung ist
fischstäbchen also gemüse fischstäbchen
also wenn die stäbchen und koche für
timo reiser und heißes wasser jetzt
machen wir ein bisschen öl in und die
kommen jetzt mensch ist das toll so eine
wohnküche vor allem ihre geräusche weißt
schon gut geht auch auf die tschechen
die zuhause werden und nur so faul auf
der couch schild so ist es auch so ist
es immer auch ich muss immer kochen für
timo flüssiges dass die leute uns nicht
so gut kennen und nicht wissen dass es
mit absoluten job ist jetzt haben wir
dass die eier müssen noch angeschlossen
werden das wasser kocht die mache ich
vielleicht mal nicht auf 900 geschrieben
die hast meine koch kannst meine videos
wenn ich nicht kurios mache deswegen
hier koch content hoch qualitativer
content
das wort cooking action mehr gibt es
nicht zu sehen
das gibt total hält auch allgemein aber
nichts zu sehen ich schreibe jetzt
einfach mal werbung kennen weil ich
jetzt kurz dieser fisch vom feld
fischstäbchen probiere mit zitrone
natürlich darauf aber das ist unbezahlte
werbung also das weiß kein agreement
veganer mein gott das war so ein
background neues ja auch vielleicht so
und dann probieren weil ich hätte diese
finger
und die werden jetzt probiert kann so
ein prima klima kommunal sagen wir bitte
das ist nicht nach einfach für stäbchen
schmeckt das gefühl panade macht mir
nicht viel aus
ja und wir haben aber auch irgendwie
diese konsistenz
die ist so dass ich doch das ist nicht
mal soja oder also original die
schwarzwurzeln sie sind so wirklich so
wurzeln die uns allerdings paniermehl
wasser jack jack frucht diese
sondern um öl talentes kasan protein
auch und blumenkohl weizenmehl das ist
halt auch das ding ich kann ehrlich
schreibe ich auch gerne gerade an dieser
stelle werbung das ist das problem bei
mir immer dass ich so soja und tofu an
das ist jetzt so ja nicht um vertrage
und ich bin bei diesen einfach mehr
länder jetzt schon klar ich will mir
schon die konspiration von winsen der
dekoriert gerade seine bude kann ich
auch hin zu bloggen ich bin jetzt login
queen geworden ich werde heute noch mein
weihnachtsmahl buch anfangen
jetzt machen wir heute nicht mehr wo ich
bin sagt ich bin durch für den tag und
[Musik]
ich zeige euch gleich mal was ich aus
meinem tageslicht anschauen
im moment ist man sich sieht na ja nicht
ein einziges highlight größten hits wie
dein gewicht während im wald wegen
seiner seite so verzogen sind alle ok
ich zeige euch mal ein malbuch morgen